je crois qu'on va jamais arrêter les ce
qu'on appelait déjà avant la guerre de
14 des interventions d'humanité oui
j'espère mais je pense qu'il faut les
encadrer et c'est ce que j'ai expliqué
en suspens il faut des trois conditions
premier conditions vous voulez virer un
moustachu qui s'appelle saad al hussein
ben salah qui vous voulez kadhafi se
terrait vous le remplacer par quoi vous
le remplacez passe avoue le remplacer
par qui c'est le premier critère est ce
que vous avez une équipe de remplaçants
fouquet pas les effets de mickey que
nous avait montré notre ami bernard
henri lévy l'hôtel raphaël qui l'avait
ramenée à sarkozy sur la libye qui ont
été bien incapable de gouverner la libye
ils ont montré des alors sommes pas que
la capacité là donc est-ce que vous avez
une équipe de remplacement la deuxième
la deuxième question voulez vous fait ça
pour protéger les populations civiles de
vous le dire vous obtenez l'autorisation
de l'onu au nom de la protection du
devoir de protection des populations
civiles
est-ce que vous pouvez simplement leur
garantir de leur situation sera
meilleure
après l'intervention militaire qu'avant
il se trouve que je suis retourné
plusieurs fois en libye après
l'intervention occidentale et je suis
retourné plusieurs fois en irak après
l'intervention occidentale je n'ai pas
trouvé une seule famille de benghazi ou
de tripoli ou de bagdad qui ne
regrettera pas le régime ancien il me
dit oui j'ai certes mais oui et je parle
je parle bien et je parle bien je parle
bien des chiffres parce que parce que
parce que la dictature politique
les gens n'aiment pas ça mais il ya pire
que l'insécurité et il y à l'anarchie il
appert que l'anarchie et à la guerre
civile
effectivement les familles chiites de
bagdad elles ont peur maintenant
d'envoyer leurs enfants à l'école c'est
le pire pour une série et c'est pour ça
voila voila j'aimerais que je parle pas
des familles chiites du sud c'est un peu
différent
vous m'avez j'ai parlé de bagdad c'est
tout à fait tout à fait un vertueux que
vous avez couvert pour le figaro tous et
tous ces conflits